dans deux jours nous serons plus de 680
mille électeurs invités à nous rendre
aux urnes que ce soit en indre et loire
ou en loir-et-cher pour désigner nos
futurs représentants à l'assemblée
nationale dans nos deux départements
huit députés doivent être élus pour une
durée de cinq ans au précédent scrutin
en 2010 est plus de 45% des électeurs ne
s'étaient pas déplacés pour voter alors
ces élections législatives sont elles
mal aimés ou méconnus du grand public
tentative de réponse avec théodore de
queiros
[Musique]
qui on élit aux gestions des
législatives
pas vraiment non j'ai plutôt à charge
lancée rien du tout je sais pas on élit
les élus ou à la mairie
je dis ce que je pense
[Musique]
j'ai re circonscription
un des buts et ça va des lois
les projets de loi pas grand chose en ce
qui me concerne
je suis enfin
ccc france est représentée le
le département les les intérêts du
département les enfin bref
[Musique]
aux valeurs la frange est une colle moi
ça ne m'intéresse plus non non non pas
du tout en face il ya un numéro
[Rires]
[Musique]
bon alors là non je sais pas si c'est
vers la mi juin
voilà c'est tros question mais n'en sais
rien du tout je crois que c'est le
12 juin le 12 et le et les jours plus
tard
[Musique]